deuxièmement je vous dirais qu'il ya
beaucoup d'autres façons de pourrir un
gosse et de coucher avec gabriel
matzneff ou la pédophilie décomplexée ce
lundi l'auteur sort un livre
vanessa virus en réponse à l'écrivaine
vanessa spring aura et son récit
autobiographique le consentement
sorti il ya un an dans lequel à la cus
d'emprise sexuels alors qu'elle n'était
âgée que de 14 ans au fond que les
enfants et les vieilles personnes les
gens de mon âge me casse les pieds
gabriel matzneff c'est près de 50 années
de propos pédophiles d'analysé sur les
plateaux télé dans ses livres il n'a
jamais caché son attirance sexuelle pour
les mineurs pouvoir les très jeunes ados
1974 il publie les moins de 16 ans un
essai qui fait clairement l'apologie de
la pédophilie je pense que les
adolescents les jeunes enfants lisent
entre 10 et 16 ans les moins de 16 ans
ont peut-être sont peut-être à l'âge où
les pulsions d'affectivité les pulsions
sexuelles également sont les plus fortes
traquer les punaises
sur le plateau la complaisance est
totale personne ou presque ne s'indigne
des propos de gabriel matzneff pas même
le présentateur bernard pivot
ce jeanne délais une institutrice et
écrivaine osent élever la voix contre
lui que voulez vous j'ai des treize de
16 ans et ça me gêne de penser combien
les draguer aux portes du lycée malgré
ses propos choquants gabriel matzneff
continue d'être invité à la télévision
1983 il est encore sur le plateau d'
apostrophes où il vient présenter son
dernier livre un récit autobiographique
sur ses jeunes années
là encore son attirance pour les jeunes
enfants est assumée et preuve de la
tolérance à son égard
des rires fusent sur le plateau vous
avez une activité sexuelle intense parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de jeunes filles
passent dans votre lit puis il ya des
petits garçons ça fait beaucoup de monde
les années passent le milieu
intellectuel est toujours aussi
silencieux voire tolérant un mutisme
assourdissant
jusqu'à ce 2 mars 1990 c'était encore
sur le plateau d' apostrophes moi
monsieur matzneff me semble pitoyable ce
coup de gueule c'est celui de denise
bombardier une romancière canadienne
maelle gabriel matzneff venu présenter
son livre mes amours développer dans
lequel ils témoignent de ces relations
sexuelles avec de très jeunes filles
denise bombardier est la seule sur le
plateau a fustigé ses penchants
pédophiles ne pas ne peut pas servir des
soli même à la littérature
il n'y a pas de limite si monsieur
matzneff était plutôt un employé anonyme
de n'importe quelle société
je crois qu'il aurait des contacts avec
la justice de ce pays trente ans plus
tard le scandale match net explosent le
temps de la complaisance est terminée au
grand soulagement de denise bombardier
elle qui salue le courage de vanessa
spring aura pas l'organiser je suis fort
que moi j'ai lancé des cris tellement
tellement la description et en distance
en quelque sorte de l'horreur la qualité
mais elle n'est pas la seule
il ya énormément de jeunes filles qui
sont passés par là et des petits garçons
on le sait
[Musique]